Speaker 1: Why don't we speak next? Just because
we're doing it and we have time. Let's speak to
Michael from New Jersey. Michael from New Jersey,
welcome to the David Pakman show. What's on your
mind today? Michael from New Jersey, Please
accept my invitation to appear on my program.
And last chance for Michael from New Jersey.
All right, Well, that's too bad. Really
seem to want to get on. Why don't we go
next to I hope I'm pronouncing this
correctly. Is it San from Israel San?
Speaker 2: It's Shaun. Thanks for.
Speaker 1: Having me. Oh, it's Shaun. Well,
I've never seen Shaun spelled that way.
Speaker 2: Yeah, my mom, she's. She's
Irish. So that's how the spell.
Speaker 1: Love it. All right,
well, what's going on?
Speaker 2: I'm from, well, from Israel.
That's a touchy subject right now, but.
Speaker 1: So your mom is an Irish Jewish person?
Speaker 2: No, she's Catholic, but near my dad
or my mom are religious. I mean, I grew up in the
kibbutz. Are you familiar with it?
Speaker 1: Of course. Yeah,
but. So hold on a second. Neither of your
parents is Jewish, But you were brought up.
Speaker 2: No, my. My dad is Sephardic Jewish.
Okay. And my mom is a Catholic Irish. But.
Speaker 1: You know, I had I had never
heard of non people with no Jewish
parents growing up on kibbutzim.
That's. But you said your dad is Jewish. Got it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I was. She was a volunteer in the
kibbutz. That's how they met. But so, yeah, I
was out there and I thought maybe, you know,
if, if there a such because I know there's
a commune in the US and it's usually they
have is this best stigma because most of us it's
like for bad reasons. But I thought, you know,
like, but the kibbutz, it's like one like great
example that actually worked for us really well,
actually, you know, like. If case some element
implements some elements of that and kind of
like or or approved some worries because.
Speaker 1: Yeah kibbutzim are interesting
and they're often use this case studies for look
this is an example of a pseudo socialized commune
type community that really works well. I think
there are a couple of things, Shawn, that are
often said in response to that. One is that do
you know, like, what's the largest kibbutz? How
many people are part of the largest kibbutz?
Speaker 2: I'm not much, to be honest. I didn't
really follow. I mean, I know my kibbutz doesn't
do well these days. Caused some bad decisions,
lost parts of their lives or something.
Speaker 1: But I guess what I'm getting
at is the two most common rebuttals to the idea
of the kibbutz as proof of communal organization
is one. Kibbutzim are relatively small, often 150
or fewer people. And even with the bigger ones,
which maybe are in the five hundreds, I think that
you're really getting to the upper reaches of when
that sort of organization makes sense. And so
a lot of times people say, Sure, do it with
15,000 people and you'll see it no longer make
sense, which of course isn't really the point of
the kibbutz. That's one thing that's that's often
said. Yeah. The other thing that's often said is,
you know, it's a bit of a copout to look
at the kibbutz as the proof of the commune
living because it doesn't stand on its own.
It exists within the state of Israel and all
of the benefits and infrastructure that the
state of Israel provides. So it's not really
a good example of self-sufficiency. The counter
to that counter would be actually a lot of these
kibbutzim are quite self-sufficient. Yeah, So
it's a it's a conversation that takes place. I
think both sides have interesting perspectives.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. And also like, all like,
do like exact same. I mean, like, well, what's
it sound like. Like a new thing. It's, it's,
it's just, it's all like, like, yeah. It's like a
sort of modern version, I guess, of a cameo. And
it's nothing new. It's not like really mentioned,
but I thought it was like, I don't know,
maybe we can take some elements of that or
improve it. In some ways. You don't need to.
Speaker 1: I agree. I mean, listen, there's been
a lot written about some of the great things that
that you see at kibbutzim, including the sort of
community child rearing that takes place where
people watch out and participate, watch out for
and help to raise all children in the community.
Yeah, the the safety there's a lot
of things I think, that are that are
interesting, regardless of your views
on socialism or capitalism or whatever.
Speaker 2: I mean, I guess that's far more,
I guess more in the socialism vibe. I mean
because I'm more that's a more familiar with
that makes sense. I mean, the kibbutz I was
growing was non-religious like this. All hams.
Speaker 1: That's all right. And remember,
every time you swear, our producer has to bleep
it, So let's try not to. Not to do that already.
Sean, listen, it all sounds incredible. I
really do appreciate you calling in today.
All right. Have a nice day. All right. There goes
Sean from Israel. We almost squeaked through today
with no bleeps, but Sean got us. He really did.
All right, everybody, That's going to do it for
today. We will take calls again. And I hope
you are one of the next people I speak to.